[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh i do need andrew brandt
and thankfully i get andrew brant every
week
on the ross tucker football podcast i
also
listened to the business of sports
podcast
andrew's up there in frank isola
category
with he's a columnist for the nmqb he
hosts the business of sports podcast
he's an executive for vayner sports
garyvee
former packers exec speaking of bratz
former espn legal and business analyst
he does stuff in villanova and he's got
the best newsletter out there
with his sunday seven which i enjoy
every morning
every sunday morning getting that stuff
andrew long time no talk how are you
ross man 48 hours how do we deal without
being
together here we are again i appreciate
all the intro
i always say of a lot of jobs so i don't
have to have a real one
i love it so andrew here's my question
you spent like 10 years in green bay
but i also know you are mr healthy
like the guy does triathlons the guy's
got ripped
six-pack abs did you partake in brats
when you lived in wisconsin
um well only when i had to
[Laughter]
i didn't want to be this anti-social guy
that shows up and they're only serving
brats and i would go ask uh
hey guys you got any tofu you know that
wouldn't have gone over well so i played
the game
but yeah i mean listen wisconsin is
where i got into
triathlon and running and biking because
you talk about a hearty group of people
i mean there are people running 350 days
a year out there with the crampons on
their shoes and the ice and snow
so yeah i mean they're they they don't
eat that healthy but they can be very
healthy out there
what's your policy on onions in general
onions are fine i'm good with onions
okay
i got no issue with onions yeah i don't
like onions
onions i i don't detest them quite as
much as mayonnaise
but they're up there mayonnaise is still
i mean
i at this point in life i just feel bad
for people that like mayonnaise uh
anyway beets beets is my thing
i'm not going near bees yeah and tom
brady's not going near onions
or mayonnaise because he knows what's up
you know what's up
so we're seeing a lot of this andrew
brady signs a four-year deal
but they're saying it's really only one
more saves a team 19 million against the
cap what what is all this going on
yeah it looks like tampa is using brady
to get their cap
relief you know we see this around the
league right now ross where teams are
bonusing out players and when you bonus
you can prorate out the bonus for the
years remaining on the contract
so you lower your cap this year so
brady's making 25 basically
takes 24 of it puts it into a signing
bonus that's prorated
adds a few years to the contract some of
them are avoidable which mean they're
just dummy years they're
for probation purposes and they lower
the cap number by 19 million dollars
i mean again you know me ross i always
say whether you're gonna you're gonna
push out
pain and you're going to have pain down
the road but tampa's manage the cap well
it's teams like the saints and the
steelers that have this
constant push out and constant
restructuring and it's going to haunt
them you're already sealing
seeing that with the saints having to
cut so many players right now
and it's hard time right now i mean this
is it ross we have never seen
a cap decrease i've been around the nfl
25 years
and here we go and teams are
slicing dyson whatever they need to do
to get under
so you i mean you already said it you
don't like this you don't like when
teams do the avoidable years you don't
like
when they push stuff out but i guess in
fairness and
they thought the cap would be like close
to 210 it's 182 so
if there was ever a year where it's
understandable this is the one right
yeah it's under yeah because people are
going to rationalize yeah we'll get the
big crappy increases with the big tv
deals
i guess my point is this ross there are
i don't know 15 20 teams maybe 15
that are not doing this right and i
am saying they are going to be more
advantaged maybe short term
certainly long term by not doing this
getting ahead of the curve having a lot
of cap room being able to load cap and
cash the same way
where you have flexibility down the road
you're not starting up hill with huge
dead
numbers on your cat talking with my
buddy andrew brandt at andrew brant
on twitter he's got the business of
sports podcast among
a bunch of different things so here's my
question about the chiefs
yesterday andrew the chiefs released
eric fisher and mitch schwartz they both
just had
major surgeries in february
now i don't know if you were ever the
guy that had to call
and cut guys i know you had great
relationships with agents and obviously
they're doing it
to save 18 million dollars against the
cap
but don't you wouldn't you feel a little
dirty
calling a guy to tell him you're firing
him a month after he just had a major
surgery
yeah and let's talk about the the
legalities here you can't cut a player
who's injured
in terms of having remaining time on the
contract that's going to pay them
now here we are in the off season so if
this was the season and you cut a guy
and an independent doctor says you know
he's got eight weeks left on his injury
you got to pay him but now there's no
game
for six months so i guess you can
legally say well
by that time you know you're still going
to be ready to play so we don't we don't
owe you any money
but you're talking about the morality of
it and that's tough
i mean mitchell schwartz eric fisher i
mean these guys are
integral to their super bowl runs and
it's just unfortunate but
that's where we are right now i i mean
you know me ross when i hear things
about player empowerment i'm like hello
have you seen february and march every
year in the nfl
you're seeing this happen you're seeing
these massive cuts that are coming
uh have been happening and are gonna cut
hundreds of millions of dollars just
vanishes is there somebody to blame for
that andrew is there somebody to blame
for the fact that a guy can have an
achilles tendon surgery in february or a
back surgery in february
and be fired in march because i mean
that doesn't happen in the other sports
no i mean what did why it doesn't happen
in the other sports is you can do all
that you just mentioned ross but you got
to pay him
and what we're talking about is lack of
future guarantees and
i've you know it's a long involved
subject but it's two parts
one can the individual agent do
something about it
which they don't seem to be able to do
past like two years you know me two
years and we'll see
and then can the union do something
about it where they would say
hey you cut a veteran before the season
you still gotta pay him pick a number
ten percent of his salary
you know that could be negotiated in
but that's never been done in football
and the lack of guarantees make it so
different than other sports
so let's get to russell wilson uh and i
guess on some level desean watson as
well
yeah you were the point person with the
agents
that was your job for the packers i see
the helmet behind you you're wearing
green
yeah what what would you be doing right
now what would you be saying to their
agents because
desean watson clearly wants out and it
kind of seems like russell wilson does
too
yeah i mean you mention it that's always
the gateway for me with players was the
agent because you have to like you
mentioned i work on those relationships
when i went on road trips and i'm in
detroit or dallas or denver i'm like i
look up the agents in that area and have
to have a drink
you know it's these kind of situations
where you need that
and and so you're going to russ's agent
and you're going to dishonestly and
saying what's the deal
how can we fix it now
i've been on this show with dan i was
wrong on wentz
saying that deshawn's not going anywhere
i'm not
saying that on russell ross because
the team you know the team has said in
houston
he's our quarterback you know we're not
trading him the team in seattle has not
said that
which to me is like oh oh i mean that is
bigger news to me than russ saying he's
you know picks these teams or whatever
it is
so until the seahawks say he's our
quarterback
that could happen so then it becomes i'm
looking at this ross how do you get
value
how do you get equal value for russell
wilson i don't want draft picks who
wants draft picks
they're not going to amount to russell
wilson so now you're talking about man
can he get the best offense player the
best defensive player on the team and
all those kind of things to
to add up but yeah it's like what's the
relationship there
and why can't it be fixed that's my
question if you were
ryan pace the bears gm yeah is there
any amount that's too much to give up to
try to get russell wilson i mean that's
one of the four teams he said
he's not going to the saints he's not
going to cowboy he's not going to
raiders it's really just the bears i
mean
what are you willing to give up for him
if you're the bears
you know i just said the opposite i
would give up a lot of picks but if i'm
the seahawks why do i care about picks
you know none of the picks is going to
amount to russell billion
will russell even if combined
so would he give up khalil mack would he
give up his best offensive player
you know not robinson because he's not
signed he's a tag player
would he give up a bunch of draft picks
that's why it's hard for me ross i can't
even come up with a package for these
teams
like if i'm the seahawks you know i'm
like
you know keep offering just keep keep
keep offering it's not good enough
and so that's why i think you won't be
traded yeah i got to ask you about the
dak
contract because i talk with you every
week on the ross tucker podcast and i
think on wednesday you said something
i've never heard you say before
i asked you what you thought about the
dak contract tell everybody tell all the
dan patrick show listeners what you
thought about
dak as it relates to him and the cowboys
he won
he won you know every marker he set a
new record first year money 75 million
three-year money 126 million for your
money 160 million
three your money is twice repeat twice
the three year money of patrick mahomes
first three years
and the most important part of all that
ross he's a free agent
at age 31 or the cowboys are leveraged
once again at age 30.
so i i just think like every marker you
look at in a contract he won and i'm
amused by the people that said
six months ago oh he heard his leverage
you should have taken the deal he got
hurt
doesn't matter he won i've never said
that
but maybe not never but i don't say that
often because management usually wins
well i win every time i get a chance to
talk with you because i learn a bunch
love getting an expert opinion such as
yourself check him out on twitter at
andrew brandt certainly check out the
business of sports podcast andrew thank
you so much
always a pleasure ross newsletter andrew
dashbrandt.com
love it andrew.brandt.com
free newsletter sunday morning love it